loot me once shame on you loot me twice
shame on me or to paraphrase former
president george w bush
fool me twice the point is you're not
gonna fool me again
i think that's what's going on right now
i think people have had enough
after after looters have burned down
multiple cities
over the past what is it now five six
days people have finally had enough the
tide is beginning
to turn i saw this here even in los
angeles
after two days ago looters burned
through
beverly hills they they smashed
storefronts
they stole stuff they decided they were
going to move up to the san fernando
valley and hit van nuys
didn't turn out as well for them up in
the san fernando valley they move past
the ritzy neighborhood right they get
into more of a working-class
neighborhood
business owners standing in front of
their shops
in that more working-class neighborhood
van nuys were standing there with guns
and they weren't going to let the
looters come on in there and guess what
happened
generally speaking the looters moved on
same thing in other parts of town as
well
there was one example i think this was
in bellevue washington
where looters were going all around
there outside seattle
and they decided to break into a cigar
shop now cigar
smokers i can tell you from experience
not the most
politically correct people in the world
so this cigar
what did he do the cigar and did he say
oh
thank you i'm sorry i know that you're
expressing your pain
i i'm i empathize with you please
take all of my property i feel so guilty
that i have property and you have not
yet
uh no that's not what happened he
actually pulled out his gun and pointed
it at them and screamed at them until
they all ran out of the shop
so you can see the guy filming is
actually shocked to hear this
say man what's he doing look at that i
was chasing him out of the shop you see
one two three
four five
six how many people are in this shop
at least six i think seven people
because this cigar store owner in a
cowboy hat holding a gun
chases them out and guess what happened
you'll be shocked to hear this
when you don't incentivize people
stealing your stuff and smashing all of
your belongings
when you disincentivize that then you
get less of that
this is a good sign because
this guy is not the only one who's had
enough we've all had enough
from business owners to local
politicians all the way up to the
president of the united states
it's been a few days that we've been
waiting for this better late than never
i say
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
finally tide turning goes all the way up
to the president uh if
if you saw it yesterday we'll go through
the president's
speech from the rose garden if you saw
it let me know what you thought of it in
the comments section
very curious to know what you think i
know there was a lot of criticism
being leveled at the president over the
past four or five days
some are saying some including me that
last night's speech
started to turn that around let me know
uh speaking of your comments in
in the comments section i i do have to
read this one is my favorite comment
from yesterday
i asked uh who is most responsible
for the riots and david uh responded and
said
he said i have a question are we
officially reopened or are the rioters
essential workers and this is like a
funny line
it also gets to something very true
about
the leftist culture that we're in which
is that in this leftist popular culture
the rioters sort of are essential
workers the left actually does rely on
the rioters
to create the chaos to give us more of
their policies
uh the squishes in our politics
were ruining everything until yesterday
the squishes in our politics were buying
a lot of
false rioter leftist premises
until yesterday we'll get to that in one
second first i got to thank our friends
over at netsuite
with this level of economic uncertainty
yeah that's the word for
it that's maybe an understatement even
businesses need systems that give them
complete
visibility into their numbers okay the
last few months maybe the last few days
have taught us what's important in life
and it's taught us that we need to
eliminate
or change all you need is netsuite by
oracle
the world's number one cloud business
system finance hr inventory ecommerce
everything you need all in one place so
you save time you save money you save
headaches
don't forget time is money whether
you're doing a million
or hundreds of millions of dollars in
sales netsuite gives you
the visibility and control that you need
to manage
every penny with precision join the over
20 000 companies
who trust netsuite to go faster with
confidence i i
absolutely love this company receive
your free guide seven actions businesses
need to
take now and schedule your free product
tour
at netsuite.com knowles get your free
guide schedule your free product tour
right now at netsuite.com
knowlescannonwlisnetsuite.com
knowles
the problem of the last four or five
days i get more than that even now of
these riots of this building up
the reason that it was allowed to go on
so long and get so bad
is that there were a lot of squishes in
politics not just on the left on the
right as well
at the local all the way up to the top
and they were buying the rioters
premises
and because they were buying the rioters
premises they were allowing the riots to
go on and because they allowed the riots
to go on
the riots got much much worse and a lot
of innocent people
got killed a lot of innocent people had
their livelihoods destroyed
nothing good came out of it what were
the two premises
the first premise of the rioters that
they bought was that
there's a national epidemic of racist
cops hunting down
innocent black guys whenever they leave
their homes that isn't true
there's no evidence that that's
happening nobody benefits from
pretending that that is true
it is simply not the case there are sad
incidents
that happen there are instances of
injustice that happen because all human
systems
involve injustice it is not possible to
get rid of injustice
people telling you that you will
perfectly get rid of injustice are
selling you a utopian lie
and historically when when people have
sold utopian lies they've bred a lot
more misery
than they were replacing that's the
first false premise the second false
premise
is that this was ever about
racial injustice or or
being heard or having a listening
session it was never about that it was
never about that
it was about stealing stuff and creating
chaos
and harming innocent people and
pursuing people's selfish appetites
that's what it was always about okay and
they
they lied to you the writers lied to you
and made you think that it was about
justice and
and peace and equality it's not it was
never about that
and only rubes would be taken in by that
con
not the case i think finally now
people realize it wasn't about being
heard because you know if you want to be
heard
smashing windows and stealing nikes is
not a great way
to be heard for days everyone seemed to
have been under an ideological spell
people thought that enforcing laws was
tyranny people thought that arresting
criminals was unjust
people thought that grievances real or
imagined
justified attacks on innocent people
none of that was true
and then people woke up to some basic
truths they woke up to the idea that law
is good order is good
violent temper tantrums should never be
indulged
and the most basic thing they learned is
that the only way to stop a bad guy with
a gun
is a good guy with a gun so while many
weak
left-wing sheriffs and law enforcement
agencies around the country were
standing down not doing anything
the good law enforcement agencies were
standing up a sheriff in polk county
florida sheriff grady judd
warned the criminals warned the writers
he said guys please
i'm pleading with you for your lives do
not
go and break into people's homes because
if you do
you're not going to like what's waiting
for you on the other side of the door we
have received information on social
media
that some of the criminals
were going to take their criminal
conduct into the neighborhoods
i would tell them if you value your life
you probably shouldn't do that in polk
county
because the people of polk county like
guns
they have guns i encourage them to own
guns
and they're going to be in their homes
tonight with their guns loaded
and if you try to break into their homes
to steal
to set fires i'm highly recommending
they blow you back out of the house with
your guns
so leave the community alone i love
the the politeness now they have guns
they like guns
and if you break in i am highly
recommending
they blow you back out of the house i'm
not ordering them too
all right this isn't a tyranny here i'm
merely making a suggestion that they use
the guns that they have and they love
to blow you out of the house to blow the
violent intruders who are threatening
their lives
and threatening their property out of
the house this kind of language i highly
encourage i strongly encourage
this recurs not just in local law
enforcement but actually all the way up
to the president of the united states
the best version
of this message came from trump trump
has been catching flack over the past
few days
trump has been catching flack because we
haven't heard from him he hasn't you
know this is the law order candidate
this is the
the guy who said i'm going to lead i'm
going to take control and be
he hasn't been publicly doing that over
the past few days
so people even trump's strongest
supporters have said where is he where
is he come on trump give us something
and he he rose to the occasion yesterday
a better light than never and he did a
really good job
there were five parts to what was
actually a very short
speech but it was a brilliant speech
whoever wrote it uh
is did a great job and whoever
delivered it which was president trump
did an even better job
here are the parts he opens up doesn't
open up with the rioters he opens up
with the inciting
incident which was ostensibly the death
of george floyd
my administration is fully committed
that for george and his family justice
will be served
he will not have died in vain
but we cannot allow the righteous cries
and peaceful protesters
to be drowned out by an angry mob
the biggest victims of the rioting are
peace-loving citizens in our poorest
communities
so he has to open up with george floyd
the reason he has to because you might
say now look these writers have nothing
to do with george floyd it's actually
even sort of insulting that he would
bring up george floyd
when he's talking about people burning
down buildings and throwing stuff
through windows and
they're totally separate events sure
but he has to reassure the country that
he's taking the george floyd
death seriously you and i know that he's
been taking this seriously from the
beginning he made a statement about it
from the beginning his doj is
investigating it from the beginning
the cop who was involved has been
arrested and charged with murder we know
that
but people who only get their news from
the mainstream media don't know that
okay so he's got to communicate when
he's communicating directly with the
american people
he's got to give the whole story even if
some of that we already know he opens up
in this very humane empathetic way with
george floyd
then he moves on to what is happening
now trump says
he is mobilizing the forces to take back
control of the country
the following measures are going into
effect immediately
first we are ending the riots and
lawlessness
that has spread throughout our country
we will end it now
today i have strongly recommended to
every governor
to deploy the national guard
in sufficient numbers that we dominate
the streets
mayors and governors must establish an
overwhelming law enforcement presence
until the violence has been quelled
if a city or state refuses to take the
actions that are necessary to defend the
life and property
of their residents then i will deploy
the united states military
and quickly solve the problem for them
now listen to the difference in language
here
i will strongly recommend that the
governors call in the national guard
we will dominate the streets so you get
this kind of
weaker language the softer language
strongly recommend
and then in the very same breath
dominate this word dominate
keeps coming up in the way trump is
talking to these governors they they
leaked
uh audio of a phone call yesterday where
trump was speaking to the governors he
said you got to dominate he probably
said the word dominate 10 times
we've got to dominate we're going to
dominate we got to dominate that's the
key here
and yet trump is being careful about
this because if trump said
forget the governors i'm sending in the
united states military not the national
guard the actual
like full-on uniformed military
into the streets of our cities and
they're gonna be ready to do what the
military does
that's a very dangerous situation
because you don't deploy the military
unless you're willing to let the
military do their job and if the
military does their job
they're going to kill civilians and if
the military kills civilians even if
it's justified
you are in a very very intense political
situation
the that will not look good forget about
an election year that doesn't
that doesn't ever look good or
justifiable even in instances where it
is justifiable
so trump is in a tight position here i
wish he'd use stronger language than
i strongly encourage but he is backed
into a tight corner
so it becomes i strongly encourage call
in the national guard a lot of them have
already called in the national guard
but if they do not do it i will send in
the troops and by the way
i am already calling in the united
states military to washington dc because
obviously washington d.c
is run by the federal government in the
district of columbia
he then moves up so that's what we're
going to do we're going to send send in
our
our boys in uniform next step what are
we going to do to the bad people
antifa the looters trump addresses them
next
those who threaten innocent life and
property
will be arrested detained and prosecuted
to the fullest extent of the law
i want the organizers of this terror to
be on notice that you will face severe
criminal penalties
and lengthy sentences in jail
this includes antifa and others who are
leading
instigators of this violence the antifa
mentioned here is important because
a lot of the people who are involved in
the violence are members of antifa
which is so it's so-called anti-fascist
it gets its name from a group of german
communists from the 1930s
and they are just as radical as german
communists from the 1930s
and they are they are a domestic
terrorist organization i ran into antifa
when i was giving a speech at the
university of missouri kansas city a
couple years ago
i was giving a very controversial speech
was called men or not women
and you know it was just kind of
shocking stuff and some wacko antifa guy
busts in
in a bandana and that was before our
public health officials forced us to
wear bandanas
all the time and he busts in and
fortunately for me he just had a super
soaker was full of a bunch of creepy
household chemicals
and all he did was manage to ruin my
blazer but otherwise i escaped
fine that is not what antifa is resting
at
around the rest of the country now
around the rest of the country antifa is
using
weapons that are stronger than squirt
guns
terrorists target civilians to achieve
political ends
that's the definition of terrorism
that's the simplest definition of
terrorism
antifa fits the definition of terrorism
perfectly it is a scandal that antifa
has not been designated a terrorist
organization yet
very good that trump did it a few days
ago very good that he called them out in
this speech
now there were other people who have
been committing a lot of looting and
violence and crime who were not in
antifa
trump did not name them probably this
was a political decision
you got to pick your battles you got to
focus on your on the threats
and the broader longer term political
threat political violence threat
has been antifa so he calls them out
then trump gets to the line that i think
is the best line
in the entire speech and he uses that
then to lead into what i thought was one
of the best moments of his presidency
we'll get to that one second first i got
to thank our friends
over at ring you know uh
it's hard to remember what life was like
before ring it's hard to remember what
life was like before a couple months ago
we are home more than usual these days
but it's still very hard to keep a close
eye on things isn't it you're getting
more deliveries
maybe some unexpected visitors these
days and that means that there are more
opportunities for packages to go missing
more opportunities for people to show up
that you don't want to show up
a lot can happen outside of your front
door and we're not always free to check
on things in person well with a ring
you can keep your home safe no matter
where you are you can be in the house
you can be at the office you can be
somewhere at a dodge but you can check
in anyway ring is on a mission to make
neighborhoods safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around
the clock from video doorbells and
security cameras to smart security
lighting and alarm systems
get a special offer right now in the
ring welcome kit when you go to
slash ring.com i love these guys i trust
them i give them out
to my friends housewarming gifts get a
special offer
ring.com knowles the welcome kit
includes the ring video doorbell 3 and
chime pro
it's all you need to start building
custom security for your home today go
to ring.com
knowles that is ring.com knowles
trump gets to the best line of the
speech
this is the thesis of the speech he's
not just addressing
the individual concerns anymore he's
getting to his broader
point about government liberty order and
justice
america is founded upon the rule of law
it is the foundation of our prosperity
our freedom
and our very way of life but where there
is no law
there is no opportunity where there is
no justice
there is no liberty where there is no
safety
there is no future we must never give in
to anger or hatred if malice or
violence reigns then none of us
is free this is some seriously
sophisticated stuff
for the people who make fun of trump and
say trump doesn't know anything about
political philosophy trump doesn't know
he doesn't believe anything he's you
know he's just a
reality tv show host okay fine maybe
maybe not but
but even if that's true then he is
hiring
some really sophisticated political
thinkers and he is having those really
sophisticated political thinkers write
his speeches
and he's sophisticated enough to know
when he sees those speeches that they're
saying something
very important we have been conned
in this country not just over the past
five days but over the past five decades
to believe that liberty is to be found
in just doing whatever you want pursuing
all your own appetites me me me it's all
just about us
individually we've been told this
certainly from the left and even
even a fair bit from the right and that
isn't true there is a relationship
between liberty and justice
james madison the federalist paper said
that the end of government
is justice it's not just liberty it's
not just this kind of shallow idea of
liberty of doing whatever we want it is
justice okay edmund burke the great
conservative philosopher said
that another word for for ordered
liberty
is justice there's this relationship
here you can't have
so i think little children believe that
if you have laws
then you don't really have freedom i
actually thought this i thought this is
a free country how come there are laws
and there are rules that we have to
follow
that's what little children think then
some people
just remain little children all their
lives and then they join groups like
antifa
and they riot with groups like black
lives matter
and they remain children until the end
of their lives
when people grow up though they realize
no actually you need rules
to have liberty you need order to have
liberty
you need rules in poetry to have a
beautiful sonnet
and you need rules in society to have a
beautiful society where everybody
has an exalted freedom and then trump
embodied this he actually he actually
put this into his own
flesh and action when he said okay this
is my thesis on liberty and justice and
order
now i'm going to go pay respects to a
very special place
and he left us on a cliffhanger what is
that special place
thank you very much and now i'm going to
pay my respects to a very very special
place thank you very much and okay
you're seeing me walk he just
he leaves it drops the mic okay i'm
gonna go pay my respects for a special
place walks
out and then he just walks out the front
door to the white house
i think most people didn't even know the
front door the white house worked
you don't see people coming in and out
of there too much he
then walks leading a group of people
including the attorney general bill barr
including
serious people ivanka's back there he
walks across
lafayette park leading it right he's not
behind the 10 secret service agents
he's leading because he has to this guy
gets stage craft
he gets optics he walks across the park
to st john's church the church that the
riders had set on fire the night before
and he walked to the front of saint
john's church and he held a bible up
he held that bible up in his right hand
didn't give a big speech just held the
bible the symbol
of that the the image of trump standing
holding the bible up in his right hand
in front of the church that they tried
to burn down it's a beautiful thing
it's a beautiful thing because it tells
us about the rules and the order that we
need to have freedom
john adams said our country is built for
moral and religious people it is unfit
to the governance of
any other kind of people that that on
the and then
the other implicit message here and what
trump is doing is exactly what we said
on this show yesterday
we said hey let's zoom out a little bit
let's remember why is racism bad in the
first place why do we why do we all
agree that racism is bad
most people can't answer that question
the reason that we think racism is bad
the reason
that we in our society unlike every
other society that has ever lived
the reason we uniquely think that racism
is bad
is because of christianity because
christianity shaped our society
man is made in the image of god we
descend from a common ancestor
there is human dignity and there is
human solidarity
we uniquely believe that and trump
showed that and of course the left
was furious including the leftists who
run that
episcopal church that episcopalian
church the there was a
a bishop of that church mary ann
something who condemned trump for
for walking to the church i got to tell
you something
i've met a fair number of bishops in my
life
never met a bishop named marianne i
don't think
bishops are named marianne just look
what do i don't know a whole lot about
the episcopalian
uh religion but uh not i just don't know
a lot of bishops
name myrian i'll leave it at that even a
catholic priest attacked him said it was
exploitative of the bible it wasn't
exploited it was perfect it was a great
image it's one of the highlights of his
presidency
why did it take so long what was the
pivot here you know
even trump's strongest supporters have
been criticizing what they viewed as
weakness so far
even including tucker carlson who by all
reports is friends with the president is
a big supporter of the president
tucker carlson took to his show on fox
to
go after what he views as the weak
squishy advisers around him
specifically he he called out president
trump's son-in-law jared kushner
some key advisers around the president
don't seem to understand
this or the gravity of the moment no
matter what happens they'll tell you
our voters aren't going anywhere the
trailer parks are rock solid
what choice do they have they've got to
vote for us
jared kushner for one has made that
point out loud
no one has more contempt for donald
trump's voters than jared kushner does
and no one expresses it more frequently
in 2016 donald trump ran as a law and
order candidate because he meant it
and his views remain fundamentally
unchanged today
but the president's famously sharp
instincts the ones that won him the
presidency almost four years ago
have been since subverted at every level
by jared kushner
this is true on immigration on foreign
policy and especially on law enforcement
as crime in this country continues to
rise jared kushner has led a highly
aggressive effort
to let more criminals out of prison and
back on to the streets
this is reckless at this moment in time
it's insane it continues to happen
now you know tucker does this a lot on
his show he'll go after a specific
person
very pointedly and that makes his
broader point so
i don't know the inner workings of the
west wing i don't know
jared kushner particularly well i don't
know tucker carlson particularly well so
i'm i'm not really commenting on that
itself
on the broader point that tucker is
making that that trump has some squishy
people around him and he should listen
to the hardcore conservative people not
the squishy people
that point is obviously correct
squishiness will not help
trump in november people want
a choice not an echo to quote phyllis
schlafly
okay from many many decades ago
when president trump is strong when he
gives an alternative
to the general liberal consensus people
go nuts for it they love it it's great
he compares
very very favorably to the leftist
adversaries that he faces
leftist adversaries who make excuses for
the rioters
and i'm not just talking about random
accounts on twitter i'm talking about
major figures on cnn
major figures in the democratic party we
will get to that in just one second
first though
i've got to thank you for subscribing to
the michael knowles show youtube channel
if you're watching this on youtube right
now probably you are
watching this on the daily wire youtube
channel that's fine that's cool whatever
look we want to help ben out you know
like we'll give him some views and stuff
but you got to go to the michael noll
show youtube channel right now
drew clavin decided to secretly
tell everyone who listens to his show to
go subscribe so that he could beat me
to get to 50 000 subscribers and i don't
know probably a
certain point that'll just get me fired
so you've got to go there right now
please my job depends on it go to the
michael knowles show youtube channel and
subscribe you get extra bonus segments
we got one up right now with my friend
matty kearns
discussing a major a transgender
decision out of the administration
so head on over by the way if you become
an all-access member you get not one
you get two leftist years tumblers that
is and i'm no mathematical expert or
nothing
double is good i believe roughly
approximate 1.9 to 2.1 times as good
head on over become an all-access member
you get a whole bunch of stuff
more hours of the bench shapiro show the
all-access show q and a's
but most importantly you get the
tumblers that's the real key
dailywire.com
subscribe get 15 off the coupon code
knowles dailywire.com
subscribe codenals we'll be right back
with a lot more
strength donald trump did not win the
republican
nomination on his first try at the
presidency
against 17 pretty strong republican
candidates
because he was a better jeb bush okay he
didn't do that he won because he was the
opposite of jeb bush
he was the foil to jeb bush he was the
foil to more liberal republicans
if we want liberalism if we want leftism
we will vote for the liberal democratic
candidate
because trump will never do liberalism
better than they do i mean they've gone
so far
cnn a reporter on cnn sarah sidner
national correspondent openly defended
and made excuses on national television
for the rioters i know people see
violence and think
that people are just taking advantage of
the situation and there may be some
people who
are i don't know that every single
person is doing this born out of pain
but i can tell you many people are we've
seen it
they don't know what to do with that
emotion so their response
especially young folks is to lash out
and one of the young folks we talked to
him on your show you
had him on your show a young man who was
from minneapolis who said
do you see all this damage here you
don't listen to us when we speak so
you listen to us now don't you
so acting out gets attention and they
know that because
the other way hasn't gotten them the
attention it hasn't done anything it
hasn't changed anything
so they're hoping this will will it i
don't know
i was in ferguson in 2014 for three
months we're back here again
same scenario just about there wasn't a
gun involved
there was a knee involved acting out
gets them attention i almost don't even
want to address all the stupid factually
incorrect things she said
like she's still perpetuating this lie
that michael brown and ferguson was shot
with his hands up saying don't shoot
didn't happen
multiple autopsies showed the guy
michael brown reached for the cops gun
the gun went off in the cop car
many many eyewitnesses all saying the
same thing she's just perpetuating that
lie
she's perpetuating this lie that there's
some justification for the riots here i
i don't even want to get into it i just
want to get into this
really dumb bit of political philosophy
a really dumb bit of parenting
she said acting out gets attention
yeah that's true everyone who's ever met
a teenager knows
everyone who's ever met a toddler knows
that acting out
gets attention but when you want to
raise a good child
you don't give them attention when they
do bad things
because that will reinforce the bad
behavior that will incentivize the bad
behavior and you know what happens then
you get more of it
but we don't know that we don't know
that anymore in our culture we don't
know how to raise another generation
that's why things have spiraled so far
out of control
there's a connection here between the
breakdown of the family and the
breakdown of civil society
people have been predicting this for
many years it's not just about orange
man bad i know you want to blame
all your troubles if you're on the left
on president trump
but it's not president trump and even if
it were president trump
america elected president trump the
trouble about a representative democracy
is you get representatives
and the representatives are
representative of you the voters
i think that president trump is actually
offering a little bit of hope to try to
get back
to something that we've lost and i think
that that longing is why people elected
him
in the first place to restore some law
order to restore a sense of justice
but you can't be in a situation where
you're indulging all of this terrible
behavior
there is no justification for rioting
these are not
genuinely wounded people who just want
to be heard
no they're degenerate criminals who are
stealing people's property and killing
people
and setting buildings on fire
it's not compassionate to anybody to be
nice to criminals
you remember we saw that video of the
woman in minneapolis sobbing
because her neighborhood had been burned
down and all the stores that she goes to
have been burned down all the places she
frequents burned down
it's not compassionate to her to be nice
to derelict criminals who should be
rotting in prison for a very long time
you wouldn't do this when you raise
children you shouldn't do this when
you're
raising a society either but you
actually see this there's this
unbelievable story that nobody's talking
about this is like a
an undercurrent of this entire problem
we're facing
which is that in multiple places now
where the writing has gotten pretty bad
the children of the political leaders
are helping the rioters
and no one wants to talk about it
minnesota governor tim waltz
he called in the national guard finally
he had done a terrible job
managing this crisis in minnesota but
finally he calls in the national guard
no sooner does he call in the national
guard then his daughter
hope waltz encourages the rioters
by tweeting out info about the national
guard's movements
so this governor's daughter presumably a
pretty
leftist lady tweets out quote
could someone who has act who actually
has followers rely to the masses i think
she meant relay
to the masses it's a language right out
of karl marx that's how marxists talk
about people they're not people they're
the masses
that have gotten national guard trending
that the guard will not be present
tonight
there's a lot of misinformation that is
further spreading fear and chaos in the
scene
at the scene of the protests the guard
cannot be sent in
within minutes it takes time for them to
deploy
because they come from all over the
state to be clear the national guard
will not be present tonight
the reason that her father had said i'm
calling in the national guard is to tamp
down
the riots that were going on and try to
save lives and try to save
people's property and communities and
then she goes out immediately and says
now don't worry the guard's not really
going to come
they're not going to come it takes too
long to deploy them she goes on
just because someone asked for something
namely her father the governor
doesn't mean it's happening right away
or even happening at all i don't know
about swat but i know
what i know is the guard will not be
present arresting people tonight it's
not just
the daughter of the minnesota governor
bill de blasio mayor of new york city
his daughter kiara de blasio by the way
when we're talking about kids we're not
talking about 12 year olds here kiara de
blasio is 25 years old
kiara de blasio was arrested at one of
these riots
yar de blasio arrested by union square
12th street and broadway is part of a
group of about a hundred people who were
throwing objects
toward cops now there's no evidence that
kiara herself was throwing the objects
toward cops we don't know
but she was with that group of people
throwing objects at cops
and she refused to disperse when the
cops tried to disperse them so she got
arrested
what a pathetic situation that the
daughter
of the elected mayor of new york is
getting arrested
because she's palling around with
rioters throwing objects at the cops
that her father's supposed to lead
no wonder that the cops repeatedly have
turned their backs
physically turned their backs on bill de
blasio
no wonder that the city is in such
absolute chaos
because we i'm not i'm not even singling
out anybody in particular
we in this country have lost our
families we've lost control of our
families
this ties in with much bigger social
questions
no fault divorce which exploded many
decades ago has left
a whole generation growing up in broken
homes generation grows up in broken
homes you'll be shocked to hear
they're not terribly well adjusted to
adulthood or to society
it's not even not their fault but as you
have family breakdown
you have social breakdown in the civil
orders you have breakdown in the civil
order you have governmental breakdowns
you have governmental breakdown
you have riots in the streets consider
how crazy this has gotten people are
comparing this to the 1992 riots
when with rodney king
in the rodney king case rodney king was
a guy he got beaten by cops
the cops were then brought up on charges
for police brutality
and they were acquitted only after they
were acquitted were there riots they
were
there were riots ostensibly because
people were outraged by the injustice of
the cops getting off the hook
but now the the cop involved in the
likely police brutality was arrested
he was charged with murder what more
could
anybody want there's no solution there's
nothing left to do
but there's rioting anyway because this
doesn't really have anything to do with
george floyd it has a lot to do
with social breakdown and then of course
our divider in chief former divider in
chief i guess barack obama
had to weigh in on this barack obama who
never let an incident
of division particularly racial division
go without commenting and fomenting more
trouble
he had to comment in a medium piece
medium is that
it's that website where you can just
anybody can post whatever they want
and it's so s the guy was so cynical all
the time but but
his advice gets to a lot of what the
left is saying to do how this moment
how to make this moment the turning
point for real change wasn't barack
obama supposed to be the turning point
for real change hope and change
the left always talks about how now
we're finally going to get universal
health care i thought barack obama gave
us universal health care
didn't he do that this is going to be
the moment of real change because
there's some racial division
wasn't barack obama's but there were a
number of incidents of racial division
michael brown trayvon martin henry lewis
gates there were all these moments
during obama's administration why wasn't
that the moment for real change
because he's not interested in change
actually obama wants the opposite of
change
barack obama wants to maintain precisely
the status quo he writes
this is a very very long piece so i'll
only read a few lines
the overwhelming majority of
participants have been peaceful
courageous responsible and
inspiring he's talking about the
protesters also known as the rioters
they deserve our respect and condom and
support not condemnation
something that police and cities like
camden and flint have commendably
understood
so he immediately starts defending
against all the images we're seeing on
tv
the rioters and he's saying no really
they're mostly peaceful he's doing the
same thing cnn does right
yeah they're mostly peaceful oh that
that's a building on fire but yeah no
ignore the building on fire they're
mostly peaceful
so that just isn't true but it's a it's
obama's noble lie he's trying to trying
to say that they're
really don't believe your eyes they're
really good people i've heard some
suggest
that the recurrent problem of racial
bias in our criminal justice system
proves that only protests and direct
action can bring about change
and that voting and participation in
electoral politics is a waste of time
i couldn't disagree more so here he goes
he gets right back to you got to vote
now i guess that's better than saying
you should take to the streets and throw
molotov cocktails
but consider how ridiculous this is
the cities that are burning to the
ground are run by democratic mayors
they're
in states run by democratic governors
they're in states that are represented
by democratic senators they're blue
states
and he's saying the way to fix this is
to vote for more democrats you're saying
that the government oppresses you and
therefore
the only way to get out of the
oppression is to vote for the exact same
people who you just said or oppressing
you
that doesn't make any sense that's not
change that's the status quo
unfortunately voter turnout in these
local races is usually pitifully low
especially among young people young
people you got to go out there and vote
for the exact same people who caused the
problem in the first place
so the bottom line is this if we want to
bring about real change then the choice
isn't between protest and politics
we have to do both so here is by
defending the protests which by the way
are really riots
he's doing something the left always
does he's encouraging the chaos
a real leader right now would say stop
it these protests aren't protests
they're riots they're looting they're
unjust
go home this the cop
who likely engaged in police brutality
has been arrested he's been charged with
murder
justice is being served go home and stop
ruining people's lives and attacking
innocent people that's what a real
good leader would say that's not what
barack obama says he does what the left
does which is
encourage the threats encourage the
disorder encourage the civil unrest
and then say the only way to maintain
the only way to stop the civil unrest
is to vote for the status quo which is
us it's the it's the stick and it's the
carrot
but the end result is always the same
maintain exactly the status quo which is
going to lead to more civil unrest and
it's going to lead to more
voting for democrats
the mayor of seattle another left-wing
place mayor of seattle
jenny durkin wants to remind you as
we're all so racially divided
you got to stay divided she tweets out i
want to acknowledge that much of the
violence and destruction both here in
seattle and across the country
has been instigated and perpetuated by
white men
we're at this moment of division and yet
these democratic political leaders all
the way up to the former president are
saying
stay divided remain divided
don't don't let your guard down for just
one minute now what the mayor of seattle
is saying
is a little bit implausible it seems a
little bit unlikely
from what the videos that we've seen all
right doesn't seem like most of the
writers here are white men but even if
that were true
even if it were true imagine saying that
i can imagine saying she said i just
want to acknowledge and remind all of
you that
the majority of this violence much of
the violence and destruction has been
perpetuated by black men
could you imagine if she said that could
you imagine what the response would be
but if it's white men then it's good you
gotta you've got to
the answer to racism is is racism in the
other direction that's what they say
that is obviously
the main thing we're focused on these
days is these riots this looting the
civil unrest
don't forget the broader context of this
we just came out of the two and a half
months
of the lockdown of the coronavirus is
going to kill us all we've got to be on
edge
all of our neighbors and our citizens
they're not neighbors and citizens
they're
actually monsters who are infected who
are going to kill us and they're going
to kill grandma and you got to stay home
remember that
that's what we were told for two months
well then that went away because we
didn't have now we don't have to social
distance because if you're going out and
protesting donald trump
and rioting and looting and creating
chaos that's good then that's the cure
to coronavirus
so we said yesterday race riots are
apparently the cure to coronavirus
so now the media can't lean back on
coronavirus well don't worry they have a
new one
here's a new one this headline of the
new york post scientists say
an apocalyptic bird flu could wipe out
half of humanity
enough enough
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
shame on me fool me twice to paraphrase
george w bush point is you're not gonna
fool me again
do not be fooled again do not be
manipulated again
do not be manipulated by people who have
a very severe
and hideous political agenda
keep calm look toward
good leadership come together
don't be divided have order have justice
there is a very pointed political
operation going on right now to rip this
country apart
don't let them do it and don't worry
about the bird flu wiping out half of
humanity because you know if it's going
to do it it's going to do it anyway so
that's fine
you'll go to a better place okay as long
as long as you get your affairs in order
now
think about what we could have been
talking about the last few days
because all we've been talking about is
cities that are burning down
we didn't have to talk about that
another thing happened this weekend
i know we think the only thing that
happened was the looting and the
pillaging and the mayhem
another thing that happened is a private
company
shot a spaceship into space and sent
american astronauts up into space
for the first time in a pretty long time
this was elon musk this was spacex and
president trump
gave a speech another powerful speech
powerful in a different way
at that launch an amazing honor you know
four years ago this place was
essentially shut down
space program was over the shuttle
program was dead
one of the secret servicemen said they
were here with the past administration i
won't tell you who
and they were here to shut down the
facility and now we're the leader in the
world
again and this is just the beginning
they're going to mars
they go to the moon but they're going to
the moon in order to go to mars it's a
platform
jim would you say that's a correct
statement that's right uh jim i want to
congratulate you i want to congratulate
the vice president
first time in a long time and we're
going to mars all right
we're going yeah we're going to go to
the moon first and then we're going to
go to mars we're going to look
upward those those are the two ways you
can either look down at the rubble
look down at the lies look down at the
rancor and division look
inward only at yourself and me me me me
or you can look upward toward the
heavens
toward what's next toward what is to
come toward what happens when we
come together band together and do
something
that is productive that is outward
looking
that is lovely that is awe-inspiring
that is the opposite of everything else
that we were told to focus on this past
weekend
those are two those are the two choices
that are being offered
all right you've got the left defending
the burning down of our cities
and you've got president trump walking
out the front door of the white house
leading people to a church that people
tried to burn down
and holding up the bible walking to that
platform at the launch of a spaceship
that's going to go right out to outer
space and saying this is only the
beginning
those are two choices and elections are
about choices
as barack obama reminds us
all of these stories that we're seeing
in the news are about that election
that's coming up in november
and and look beyond that election which
country do you want to have
the choice is ours in a representative
republic
such as our country the representatives
represent
us what is it do we want to keep going
down this path of destruction or do we
want to say
enough is enough and take another course
that's our show i'm michael knowles it's
the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies and directed by
mike joyner executive producer jeremy
boring
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director
pavel wadowski editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20. hey
everybody it's andrew clavin host of the
andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon is turned to
blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clayton